right Chris
show me your chop passing please I'll
show you do here Sydney heat up at
semi-loads and so you wanna see for real
what what what slightly scary but right
seriously are you big menace are you a
big fan of the 70s allows you know God
and I wasn't born until the kind of mid
80s what we're going to be the 24 um
yeah I like certain things from the 70s
time to plate up right curse you are
going so Giles yes this is an exciting
part now yeah here we go
okay drain your fees in the colander
okay drain them off back into the pan
okay good now first the most important
part on the plate
take your steak okay steak go is at six
o'clock okay Kelsey keep up with me
darling
yeah I know you haven't got your alga
here but you can manage come on okay now
from there
next of that Holmes TomSka is that so
different items yeah take a Rosalie so
okay there's one stay aside potatoes
look absolutely fantastic well done good
hey now if all potatoes on the plate
just took the pan slightly so we don't
get any sauce you just leave it we won't
put it on at the end thank you for
asking
okay question thanks man okay raise now
okay okay
frozen so I'm full of goodness open
that's very sentence is very empty good
now okay lastly okay a delicious sauce
now the color the sauce should look like
a sort of cafe au lait smell is amazing
okay huh peas
sauce nice and generous now that smells
amazing
well the money keep on and there you go
and that's it that's the most amazing
steak I am also divert agencies done